on March 27th President Donald Trump
signed a two trillion dollar stimulus
plan aimed at combating the economic
consequences of the corona virus
pandemic but the bailout comes with
strings attached a ban on share buybacks
and dividends for any company receiving
a government loan from the stimulus
package the ban will last the term of
the government assistance plus one year
this clause was added after critics
argued that companies like Boeing and
Airlines have spent too much money
buying back their own shares from the
stock market money they could have been
saving for a rainy day we'll explain but
first you have to understand how
buybacks work in 2017 Trump's tax
overhaul left companies flush with cash
over the following two years companies
on the S&P 500 bought back an estimated
1.5 trillion dollars of their own shares
from investors the purpose of the tax
cut was not directly to encourage staff
bad backs the purpose the tax code was
to encourage companies to bring money
home and put it to more productive use
in the United States economy in common
share buybacks the company buys back
shares on the open market leaving fewer
shares outstanding this boosts a metric
called earnings per share or EPS EPS is
calculated by taking the company's net
income and dividing it by the number of
outstanding shares when the divisor
shrinks the EPS goes up higher earnings
per share makes the stock look more
attractive to investors which can push
up the share price there's a raging
debate about you know the benefits of
buybacks and how they work but I think
the people who support them would say
first of all that they do benefit
shareholders and shareholders don't have
to be you know rich people or hedge fund
owners they can be pension funds who pay
money to wide ranges of people including
a lot of organized labor they also
according the advocates benefit the
economy as a whole
critics of buybacks say it's part of a
whole distorted incentive system for
corporate America they say that a lot of
it is related to the fact that corporate
executives now themselves get paid with
stock the reason the debt has evolved
over time was to try and more closely
align the incentives of CEOs with
holder's but it also in the minds of
buyback critics has created a perverse
incentives where it's also given CEOs an
elevated incentive to worry more about
the share price than about long-term
investments or investing in their
workers buyback activists saw the
stimulus package as an opportunity to
implement limitations the stimulus sets
aside at least fifty billion dollars for
cargo and passenger airlines and
seventeen billion for businesses deemed
critical to national security such as
Boeing this comes after the corona virus
pandemic caused a severe dip in
ridership sending shares into freefall
critics point out that over the past ten
years the biggest US airlines have spent
ninety six percent of their free cash
flow on buying back their own shares
American Airlines said it's put
considerably more money into capital
investments and its team than buybacks
in recent years the aircraft
manufacturer Boeing is also expected to
receive aid from the stimulus package so
the criticism about buybacks and
corporate behavior
aimed at airlines and Boeing and in some
sectors looking for federal money
specifically because they are looking
for federal money the argument is that
if you are asking taxpayers for funds
that first of all we need to attach some
strings so you're not abusing that money
a lot of that is sort of a hangover the
2008 bailouts whether it was a feeling
those banks got tax payer funds then
they used it to pay big bonuses to their
executives as buybacks have increased in
recent years they've become a
contentious issue in Washington
Democrats have long favored restrictions
on buybacks before this latest crisis
and they see this crisis in a way as an
opportunity to begin to impose new
government restrictions on them
Republicans in general have taken the
opposite point of view feeling like it's
illegitimate for the government to weigh
in imposing new limits on how companies
spend their money
president Trump surprisingly in recent
days has taken essentially the
Democratic view and has echoed their
views that buybacks are not a legitimate
way of using corporate money at a time
of crisis over 500 billion dollars in
support for the hardest-hit industries
with a ban on corporate stock buybacks
which is something I answer
the inclusion of an anti buybacks clause
in the stimulus package is a big win for
those who oppose buybacks but even with
the stimulus in place the US economy is
still shaky because of this most
companies are staying focused on
liquidity rather than buybacks this is
really a true crisis where companies are
not as much worried about propping up
their own shares is just preparing for
those survivals injected this moment a
lot of companies are cancelling share
repurchase plans cancelling dividends
trying to keep as much cash on hand as
they can in order to make it through the
next few difficult weeks and lots